[Music]
what do you think my mother
in istanbul turkey has in common with
the first lady of the united states
let me give you a tip what they have in
common is not the fancy house
i grew up in a modest home with lovely
parents
when my mother got home from work every
day she had a four hour second shift
a shift made up of grocery shopping
cooking cleaning laundry
ironing helping me with homework
preparing me for school
my mother worked a full-time job and on
top of that when she got home she
carried the burden of
all of this traditional household duties
duties that many women tend to shoulder
when they're in relationships with male
partners
just as my mother is expected to perform
domestic
work unpaid the first lady is expected
to perform community work
on an unpaid basis my mother and the
first lady are both
expected to perform these duties by
default
in order to advance the well-being of
their husbands
of their communities and of their
families
look we expect the first lady to perform
a demanding full-time job
for free she conducts speaking
engagements
event planning household management
strategic advising
a cool job that money magazine expects
would pay 287
000 a year in washington d.c
yes the first lady is not the average
woman
but she still reflects society's
expectations of the average woman
the expectation of free labor for women
is so ingrained in our
collective psyche that even the first
lady is not
immune to it but here's a plot twist
we just elected our first second spouse
so what happens when mr kamala harris
becomes the expectation
becomes the norm and not just the
exception
what happens when more women are in
charge and what happens if their
partners
are men how many of those men are going
to agree to quit
their jobs and hang up christmas
decorations
first spouses have been women for all of
history
and sadly society has become complacent
in the expectation of free labor
from women look
men are four times more likely to
negotiate for a raise than women
if the first spouses had been man all
along
i have a feeling that they would have
revolted and asked for a raise
a long time ago
so what if we made it
optional and we gave the first spouse
the option to opt in
to perform the duties of the office as
opposed to just expecting their service
as an extension of their spouse
what would happen if we compensated them
when they opt-in
what would happen if we made an example
at the very top
that domestic and community work is
worthy
of recognition what would that mean
for women around the country
the first lady is very important because
she's symbolic even though
she has privileges that come as a result
of her office
so let's discuss who carries the real
burden
why this is the time to talk about this
and what we can do to resolve the issue
the real burden of unpaid work falls on
underprivileged women lower income women
and especially
women of color let's take a step back
and look at the big picture first the
federal reserve estimates
that women's contribution to the u.s
economy
annually in form of domestic work is
about 1.2
trillion dollars that is the size
of the new york economy that number for
women globally was 11 trillion dollars
the sizes of japanese german and indian
economies
combined this work is so critical
that in 1975 icelandic women just quit
taking care of their homes and their
children for one day
it is reported that the whole nation
came to a standstill
and let's talk about women of color
because women of color
don't just carry the burden of unpaid
domestic work
they also carry a whole history of
injustice
and the consequences of it nina banks
associate professor at bucknell
university researched
how community activism is yet another
form
of unpaid labor that is conducted by
black women
and other marginalized women of color
this work has this grassroots movements
have provided
food security and housing security to
their communities for decades
but they have been improperly
categorized as political work
when really they should be categorized
as labor
labor that fills in the gaps where
public
and private institutions have failed
marginalized communities
but why now you might ask why is this
the time to take
action because thanks to the pandemic
and failed systems women are reaching a
breaking point
they're losing their jobs and they're
experiencing the increased burden of
housework and child care
disproportionately according to new york
times 5
million women have lost their jobs
during the pandemic
over 30 percent of those women ages 25
to 44
said that child care was the reason for
that unemployment
we are back to 1980s levels of women's
activity in the workforce
and guess what black and brown women
have been hit
absolutely the hardest
let's not forget one more thing women
have also
care have also been carrying the
increased mental health burden of the
pandemic
disproportionately about 70 percent of
mothers say that they
experience adverse health effects due to
the stress of the pandemic
compared to about 50 of fathers
but also let's remember that the
pandemic did not
create this crisis the pandemic just
highlighted
the inequalities in our broken systems
so you might be thinking what can we do
about it
as individuals as employers and as
government officials
let's start as individuals firstly we
can start by challenging our own biases
because it's only when we create
individual awareness
that we can challenge greater systems
and challenge the unequal ways in which
our communities
view gender norms as a place to start
we can challenge the prevalent norm that
in many communities and cultures
mothers are the ones who are expected to
step into the role of the primary parent
we can make it okay for fathers to be
full-time fathers
and if they choose to do so we can
remove any stigma
and relieve them of the stigma
surrounding that decision
another thing we can do is to decouple
housework
from gender norms there's actually a lot
of studies that have shown
that housework is actually split more
equitably in same-sex
relationships we can change our mindsets
such that heterosexual couples also sit
down to have those
difficult conversations to decide how to
divide the labor equitably
without just defaulting on traditional
gender roles
next what can we do as government
officers
well mandating table stakes maternally
would be a good place to start
let me just recount this shocking but
still true statistic
that the united states is the only
developed country
that doesn't provide national statutory
paid
maternal leave but
that's not even enough fathers should
also
be able to take statutory parental leave
this will not only help fathers not only
help mothers
in relationships heterosexual
relationships but it will also help gay
fathers take the time that they need and
deserve
to be able to take care of their
children
another thing that the governments can
do is to really prioritize
investments in preschool programs
especially in lower income communities
and let's remember that over 70 percent
of all seats in the congress
and all statewide elected offices are
occupied by
men change will not happen
until male allies in power take these
ideas
and put them into legislation
and lastly what can we do as employers
since this is the business school as
employers
we can provide parental leave even when
men not mandated by the government
we can also make sure that our employees
take the leave
and we can eliminate any cultural stigma
and relieve them
of any penalization that comes from
their temporary absence
beyond that we can also take all of our
learnings from the pandemic
and apply them after the pandemic we can
make flexible work
and remove work accommodations available
to families
especially especially the families who
are taking care of children
and the elderly and let's remember
that today in 2021 more than 90 percent
of ceos or fortune 500 companies are
men so male allies
at this top business school ready to
take over
boardrooms and executive offices in not
too distant future
you have the power to change
organizations
you have the power to set in place
policies
that counteract the status quo
and all of that starts when we start
noticing the biases in our minds
in our hearts and in our social norms
and let's not forget to make an example
a symbolic example at the very top
let's pay the first lady thank you
[Applause]
[Music]